il est intolérable que des barbares
boost achu viennent compromettre les
plans de césar je t'avais prévenu
architectes les gaulois n'aime pas qu'on
se promène dans leur forêt leur forêt
mais arrêtez de boucher s'il vous plaît
junon mais où est ce qu'ils se croient
se croient chez eux
c'est bien le problème ah oui et bien
place à la civilisation leurs forêts on
va là des boisés faudrait là des
gauloises et d'abord pour ça je te
rappelle que ces arts compte sur toi et
geste il avait senti que se passe-t-il
travailler plus pour gagner plus les
esclaves se plaint de l'inactivité
il s'ennuie les opérations sont
momentanément suspendues pour cause de
sécurisation du site
comment comme quoi j'ai rien compris ou
ne sais pas grand angle aigu surtout le
répète pour éviter les gaulois il faut
travailler la nuit
un chantier de nuit c'est n'importe quoi
zack te ment comme votre bandage
centurion pardonne moi mais mes
collaborateurs et moi même sommes
indécis devons-nous tiré et c'est pas
vrai combien de fois il faut vous le
répéter vous attendez mon signal et
qu'elles et ils t'ont signale déjà
qu'elle est il bon signal pour la 30e
fois c'est quand je lève le bras
tout à fait
qu'est-ce qu'on attend par jupiter
j'attends le rapport de mai éclaireurs
de rien les camarades et monde pense que
tu fais trop de contrats avec le petit
architecte énervé c'est trop cher
tourner dans les rangs mais qu'est-ce
que vous fabriquez tu veux lever le bras
mais pas du tout menacé même que du coup
claque j'ai donné le signal et
éclaireurs aux rapports mais mais nous
étiez vous à la la mais vous éclairer
quoi là on a préféré pas trop s'éloigner
je parviens à cause de quoi
échantillon revenez immédiatement bande
d'abrutis